[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est le responsable départemental des
restos du coeur dans les yvelines c'est
l'invité du v y paie vip d'aujourd'hui
lyonnais l'escaut vite
bonjour bonjour merci de m'avoir invité
vous êtes bénévole si je me trompe pas
depuis 2012 au un peu plus même plus
assez la date que j'avais plus que ça
depuis 2009 2009 vous êtes bénévole or
depuis 2009 pour cette association
fondée par coluche et ça c'était en 1985
pour la création
on parle beaucoup de crises de la
vocation de l'engagement des bénévoles
aussi qu'est ce qui vous a motivé pour
vous engager
donc en 2009 alors en 2009 je terminais
juste quelques mois avant ma carrière
professionnelle
fin 2008 de mi 2008 et puis j'ai été
contactée début 2009 ham premier premier
semestre 2009 par des collègues de
l'ancien de mon ancienne entreprise qui
était qu'il y avait un ami qui était en
recherche de bénévoles pour une
association pour faire le métier de le
métier d'auditeurs voilà donc voilà donc
les coordonnées sont donnés et puis non
pas un contact est pris et je découvre
que ce sont les restos du coeur donc je
moi ma démarche c'est ce que je dis
souvent je n'ai pas intégré les restos
par vocation
une association c'est un concours de
circonstances il cherchait je cherchais
aussi pas forcément de manière très
importante mais et voilà c'est le
concours de circonstances la rencontre
ouais ça sert à ça fait 10 ans et ça
fait dix ans donc c'était en 2009 et
ensuite vous en est devenu le président
il ya tout un travail quand même
j'imagine sur la longueur pour occuper
ce poste absolument alors là 2009
jusqu'à 2012 donc si vous parlez de 2012
effectivement ce sont des missions
d'audit au sein des restos du coeur sur
l'ensemble de la du territoire français
il ya cent dix sept associations un
resto du cac
donc voilà donc je ne suis pas tout seul
évidemment nous sommes à l'époque avait
une douzaine de collègues bénévoles pour
faire ce genre de job
voilà et ça ça dure trois ans le ensuite
le poste de trésorier de l'association
yvelinoise des restos se libère trois
ans dont parcourir la france c'est bien
mais bon
donc ça me rapprochais de mon domicile
tout simplement et donc voilà j'ai
candidaté pas de problème je suis devenu
donc le trésor et deux ans après donc en
étant 2014
je prend la succession du en tant que
responsable départemental donc je
deviens président de l'association des
yvelines voilà à peu près le parcours
que vous avez eue au sein des restos
aujourd'hui c'est un travail à plein
temps parce qu'il ya tout de même il va
leur préciser cette soirée reste il ya
alors c'est un travail à quinze mille
bénéficiaires
voilà c'est un travail à plein temps
c'est clair j'arrive parfois sauver un
vendredi après-midi
les vacances sont en général difficiles
à ce qu'elles soient tranquilles
oui c'est un job à plein temps d'autant
plus que au delà glissions des yvelines
je suis administrateur national et
membre du bureau national
et ça depuis quatre ans ce qui permet de
faire remonter les problèmes de terrain
les problèmes que rencontrent les
personnes accueillies les problèmes de
bénévoles donc de faire remonter tout ça
au niveau de l'organisation nationale
voilà donc oui 15000 personnes
accueillies dans les yvelines un million
et demi de repas 24 centres de
distribution en entrepôts une résidence
sociale de dix appartements à poissy
deux chantiers d'insertion à
aubergenville un autre clayes-sous-bois
dont le
l'activité de base et la rénovation et
le démantèlement d'ordinateurs dont il
ya vingt-six salariés en insertion qui
travaillent donc sur ces deux chantiers
et puis des actifs d'autres activités
les ateliers de français mais à toutes
les activités de culture loisirs n'y a
pas que la campagne d'hiver sur bien
préciser on assez souvent parler des
risques
l'athlète a redonné du temps de l'année
sur de multiples missions absolument
toute l'année le thème c'est aujourd'hui
en ce moment c'est un repas ne suffit
pas et donc des activités donc tu le
disais les ateliers de français le
loisir culture cinéma départs en
vacances soutien recherche d'emploi
microcrédit accès au droit et à la
justice enfin voilà donc bon nombre
d'activités qui complètent évidemment le
tout le dispositif alimentaire le plus
difficile aujourd'hui c'est de garder
ses bénévoles de trouver aussi de
nouveaux bénévoles avec des besoins qui
sont plus en plus fort alors
effectivement nous avons 1200 bénévoles
le turn over est important il n'est pas
plus important dans les yvelines
qu'ailleurs il ya en moyenne de 30% donc
à 14 9 heures comme ça il faut être tout
le temps à l'affût de pour le recruter
et surtout fidéliser et motiver et
fidéliser ses bénévoles et là les
problèmes que l'on rencontre depuis pas
mal d'années ce sont des bénévoles qui
souhaitent prendre des responsabilités
animer les centres de dispositions
animer les activités dont on vient de
parler et ça ça devient très difficile
là il ya effectivement un tournant sur
ce type de bénévolat donc vraiment vous
l'expliquer on est dans une société plus
replié alors on demande effectivement
professionnalise de plus en plus le
bénévolat ça c'est clair on demande des
bénévoles
spécialisé donc en fonction de leur
carrière professionnelle passe est
évidemment mais on demande des
spécialisations professionnalise le bdi
voilà bon et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
a affaire à des personnes qui ont plus
envie de faire du bénévolat
je dirais de plaisir mais bien
évidemment qu'il faut qu'on se fasse
plaisir en tant que bénévole mais il ya
un moment donné c'est tellement
engageant que la contrainte la pression
allait l'arc et chats je crois que ça
intéresse un peu moins voilà vous l'avez
accepté dès le début vous cette
contrainte cette pression au bout j'y
suis rentré très vite c'était l'accord
un peu la continuité de la carrière
professionnelle en fait oui je m'en
faisais la question est comment vous y
rendre vous êtes rentrés par les audits
c'était une évolution de votre caf avant
une suite d'évolutions fonctionnelles
dessus toile absolument exerciez telle
quelle profession parle à moi j'étais
directeur administratif et financier
dans des grands groupes industriels donc
voilà effectivement c'était une approche
nous dit c'était une approche que je
maîtrisais assez bien donc voila c'était
c'était naturel quoi vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure que l'arrivée au resto
s'est fait presque par surprise puisque
vous ne saviez pas que c'était les
restos du coeur néanmoins lorsque
l'appel a été lancé en 85 par par
coluche vous l'avez entendu cet appel à
l'époque je la dérange la détente je
l'avais entendu bien évidemment je
connaissais le reste au fond c'est une
association qui est connue reconnue même
ne serait ce que sur le plan médiatique
avec les tyagi qui sont en
train de démarrer leur spectacle à
bordeaux là depuis hier donc là bien
évidemment mais mais sans plus quoi
voilà sans plus écologique s'est dit
quoi même à l'époque en entendant parler
de cette création d'une association
comme ça tu c'était que c'était quoi un
échec des pouvoirs publics qu'ils
n'intervenaient pas si je ne les ai pas
s'il ya ou l'agent n'était pas là en 85
j'étais encore en activité j'irai bon je
me posais beaucoup moins de questions
sur sur ce plan là moi mon engagement il
s'est confortée quelques mois après mon
début aux restos du coeur
quant au fur et à mesure des missions
que je faisais rencontrer tous ces
bénévoles de terrain qui qui a qu'eux
qui écoute qui oriente qui accompagnent
je me suis dit mais je ne me suis pas
trompé voilà c'était bien ça voilà
coluche qu'on voit à l'écran juste
derrière vous c'est une figure
aujourd'hui qui revient beaucoup nous la
part des gilet jaune c'est un modèle
pour eux c'est un peu ça pourrait être
leur porte-parole encore aujourd'hui
coluche qui est donc cette aura là et on
entend aussi certains gilet jaune dire
mais les restos en tout cas les
célébrités on les a pas entendus ceux
qui se battent au quotidien qui font des
spectacles récolter des fonds est ce que
vous pensez que les îles les jaunes à
fente ou quatre les réseaux devrait
entendre les jets les geôles et les
soutenir aussi peut-être s'engager alors
dans les valeurs dans les valeurs resto
on va dire il y a le non engagement
vis-à-vis du religieux et vis-à-vis du
politique et donc les restos font très
attention à ne pas se positionner vers
tel ou tel mouvement
beaucoup de monde a regardé l'émission
politique d'hier soir sur france 2 il ya
eu effectivement des commentaires de la
part d'un gilet jaune d'une chez les
jaunes qui reprochaient clairement aux
restos du coeur de ne pas s'être
positionné quoi mais nous ne pouvons pas
nous positionner ce n'est pas notre rôle
de nous positionner auprès auprès d'un
mouvement politique et c'est devenu un
mouvement politique puisque mon parti a
été actée qu'on a été constituée on m a
dit noter que cet art tôt dans la partie
en a qui partent sous android voilà donc
nous nous suivons notre ligue et donc
vous ne vous engagerez pas pour en tout
cas en faveur des faveurs des gilets
jaunes seulement pas nous participerons
aux grands débats mais évidemment on a
des choses à dire dans les quatre axes
du grand est mais nous nous
positionnerons pas pour
ou contre un mouvement justement alors
vous qui vous êtes engagés en 2009 en
tant que bénévole sur ses dix ans vous
avez vu une évolution de la pauvreté
pauvreté aussi des gens qui venaient
vous voir parentale est alors beaucoup
beaucoup plus de ça deux femmes deux
femmes isolées avec enfants de familles
monoparentales surtout femmes et enfants
c'est effectivement notre première note
public que nous accueillons le puce sont
venus rejoindre sur les trois quatre ans
qui viennent de passer les personnes
âgées les retraités sont venus rejoindre
également les restos assez récemment
quelques années trois ans peut-être
les étudiants de jeunes sont venus
rejoindre également récemment des
travailleurs dits pauvres c'est-à-dire
travail précaire c'est donc voilà il ya
quand même une évolution de la
population qui pousse la porte du reste
mais les restos devait être une
initiative temporaire oui aujourd'hui on
est bien loin de ça c'était en 85 vous
le déplorez comme si je voyais et
l'évolution et le cas des réseaux ou
bien sûr que nous déplorons j'irai on ne
peut souhaiter que de disparaître
évidemment mais disparaître pour laisser
les choses en l'état
non évidemment donc effectivement nous
travaillons nous travaillons aussi pour
le futur
vous imaginez si magique évolution aussi
laisser lyon on s'imagine encore être
présent comme albert merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à cette émission on en
sait un peu plus sur vous et puis sur
les réseaux bien évidemment les restos
du coeur des yvelines que vous présidez
si vous souhaitez devenir bénévole si
vous souhaitez apporter aussi être des
dons vous avez tous les renseignements
qui se sont affichées merci beaucoup à
vous
[Musique]